he's got his number he knows exactly
which one he is anna look at the double
guy that does manage to get up to the
high ground but something's with the
buyback he's there ready to claim the
kill
psg lgd 2-1 up at the moment in this
best of five grand finals one game
needed to secure the championship title
opened up onto him army trying to get on
top of anna the bkb popped by chalice
he'll get the alt out hotel getting out
straight away by f5 with the surfboard
no tail step for a hundred
if psg lgd can find that one team fight
it could be the team fight to win t.i
he gets the hex up for their fight with
the stone will say they get the bad shot
sonus will be able to fight the iron but
they're fully low ogd that song is never
two minutes they get thompson thompson
never do but it's only anna anna can you
do it here he said elsa
he gets the goal
of his lifetime
before we get into the video i wanted to
remind you that every second counts is
brought to you by cisco powering the
future of esports
alright so og were the last team that
anyone expected to make it into the
grand finals of the international 2018
literally on top of sitting dead last in
the power rankings this once perennial
powerhouse had become a broken battered
underdog after being abandoned by their
captain drafter and figurative brother
fly just three months before the biggest
tournament in dota it was a huge shock
like we for sure didn't see it coming
not much was said i think max three
sentences were spoken in that room
then they left
we spent eight years together and now
it's over
that was how that happened what happened
next is considered the greatest story in
esports and chances are you already know
it because
it is instead of rolling over and
disbanding og cobbled together a roster
fought their way through an open
qualifier regional qualifier and a
groove stage to somehow make it into the
upper bracket at the most cutthroat
international ever from there things got
even crazier og swept vgj storm and then
played a close grudge match series with
eg defeating their former captain fly og
had gone from underdogs who weren't even
supposed to be in the tournament to
prospective ti finalists one win away
from the series that every dota pro
dreams of playing og entered the upper
bracket finals against chinese super
power psg lgd as extremely hopeful
hopefuls but in typical og fashion they
went from standing on the brink of
defeat to making an impossible turn i'm
a still very very low the blast will
kill him off but buy back lgd want this
now lgd or can they back enough no
they're not terrorblade bt's forward the
ball is up thompson needs to defend x
over very visible you've got a very very
low life mirana but og they can't find
the target x nova he's got the grip he's
got the control he's got the kill
thompson is down but he is up where the
echo
slams
there's your slam there's the dumb
there's the play girax the savior of og
they have a good opening to actually
close out the game but they go for the
throne lgd want this now they basically
try to win right then and there and that
was a big mistake they weren't patient
they couldn't wait i remember the second
day buyback the tv we started laughing
about it we're like what the hell do
they think they're doing like they
actually lost but these are the moments
when like you're you're so in the zone
that you don't even realize that this is
a game three they might win they might
like it's not about that it's like
you're looking at the game and strictly
the game
and yeah for us when our game
understanding told us that this playback
was a huge mistake that we could we
could punish
leaping forward all he has to do is
create space for og to do it to get to
the grand final of t.i.a
[Applause]
against all the odds og earned a chance
to vie for the aegis of champions even
crazier was the fact their grand finals
opponent was the very same team they
barely just beat and it looked like psg
lgd wouldn't be caught off guard a
second time or so it seemed pull the
creep wave away he'll zip across but
jared with the echo snap the orchid
comes out onto the shake of the triangle
jungle but the cell fuels keeps jarraxx
alive he's safe
trying to run bishop found the strike do
they have the damage in time they do
oh gee
again and again and again in this game
one
pulling off these these incredible plays
and g
g is called ladies and gentlemen oh gee
taking game one of this best of five as
they're three dead on og
psg lgd with a full lineup still alive
as they look towards the mid laner gg is
called
ladies and gentlemen psg lgd
taking game two with the best of five
grand finals here at tia snotel
immediately dies after buying back and
winter's curse is there on to fy will it
kill him off fy still alive and why
he'll finally fall the dragon slate for
jacks finishes him off he'll buy back
those he knows this is lgd's chance to
claim this game three somnes conceived
to beat down onto the agent of the light
strike comes out the angle is tied
that's from army keeping something safe
he gets the concoction out into
jerusalem he's looking to die towards
the fountain as oh gee i still having to
play around it but the damage from
saunas in those challenges as well with
the private sprinters they beat down on
the ancient psg mgd looking to close
this one up and they will game three
goes to pst lgd
og may have won game one but lgd struck
back with two games in a row to get to
match point going into game 4 it seemed
like og's luck had finally run out like
they couldn't possibly have any more
insane comebacks or unthinkable upsets
up their sleeve it looked like lgd was
about to quickly end og's dreams in one
brutal game lgd is going to just make
them look worse because of how amazing
they are and lgg they're warmed up right
you know that they already started to
stay they had the lower bracket and they
proved that their team that can finish
things when it has to get done early and
that's something that og have been
beating teams with you know if you don't
close this game fast enough we're gonna
get this anna specter you know we're
gonna buy back on two heroes and team
wipe you and suddenly we're winning
that's pretty much what's brought og
several victories throughout this
winners bracket but in that game with
og's back against the wall with
everything to lose that one split-second
decision one seemingly impossible play
changed everything they get thompson
thompson never did
can he
[Applause]
like all great plays this one began long
before seb hit his infamous call let's
break it down second by second any dota
fan knows that games are won and lost in
the draft and at first it seemed like
lgd might have sewn up game 4 before it
even began you see seb knew that he'd
need an offlaner that could not only
enable thompson's invoker but also buy
time for anna's phantom lancer to come
online late game what's more he needed
something that could bully lanes in the
early to mid game and ideally shut down
ami's hard carry more fling the issue is
that lgd knew that too so they banned
his most viable option centaur forcing
seb to rely on something a little less
traditional
they banned the centaur oh
axe might be very good actually
well actually just cut waves against eng
and then acts against the morph yeah
yeah this might might be the next game
stand back yes
[ __ ] yes ma'am okay yes
you're gonna see man you're gonna see
some [ __ ]
can they do it here is this the ti
winning game boys we're seeing again oh
gee trying something a little different
there's the axe another hero that people
just aren't playing but they're bringing
it out here on their potential knockout
game of the cia grand finals the
question of course was whether it would
pan out in addition to being out of meta
axe is an extremely snowbally hero his
high damage rng activated spins make him
a menace in the laning phase but if he
doesn't get off to a truly excellent
start he's essentially dead weight
thankfully as soon as game four started
seb came through on his promise and from
the get-go just ran lgd into the ground
a lot of weight is gonna be on set he's
had this bottom lane he's got good
levels and he's got decent farm too he's
top of the net worth this game very
close to having the blink dagger on top
of the ring of health
but tp's are heading down so i'm just
seeing if we can find the rupture
several oh he goes to farm that's going
to give time for sumness to close the
gap get the rug trove he's still pretty
beefy but is he beefy enough i don't
think so the shards are out trapping him
in the spin though the taunt the
sunshine
the snowball safe wasn't in time
he said with the tether oh gee they're
turning this one around they look to run
down their fight flight with the
snowball the shots already used there's
no way to escape or maybe the dukes
isn't enough it is set he gets fogg he
can't get the dunk off fy will survive
unfortunately the rest of og weren't
getting off to such a great start with
tops and an anna falling behind and farm
it was up to seb to create space and
opportunities for his cores he tries to
go for example but it's over just out of
range still the spirits hitting into him
they'll chase down do they have the
damage to burst him the culling blade
just enough to bring him down so he gets
bursted by the sunstrike by the primer
split they've got the snowball in onto
anna back up his inbound set he's on the
side can he look for the play jumps in
gets the call the sun's tracked down as
well as that is back in they get the dog
off they'll kill off fy but now anand
said they've got to somehow get out of
it almighty into the axor manages to
punch down anna steps in trouble too he
looks for another call off can he get
the spins that's the question jericho's
comes in he's giving him the
regeneration
gets the second he finds the double kill
that's the bait play they get the call
on to the two of them sev jumps in the
sun strikes down the stun as well the
micro play they've got the lock down on
the boat for the summoner's falls as
well no tail with his army of creeps
as oh gee they're a member up and owner
on this he's on top of zombies the bkb
of course now won off but they'll find
strongness as well
a double kill for thompson as og take a
successful fight around the pit they're
at a 74 win probability now but lgd
weren't willing to go down without a
fight they started playing around seb's
axe avoiding him as necessary and little
by little that lead that og had amassed
started slipping away and getting
focused thompson trying to compete for
the side with the combo with the
snowball again from f5 buying time for
something little set for something he
just beats into the playbook steps able
to turn and get the kill they'll be the
buy-back for the black and trying to
hold silver chalice he's got his number
he knows exactly which one he is anna
look at the double guy that does manage
to get up to the high graph at somness
with the buyback he's there ready to
claim the kill oh gee now one game away
from
losing in this grand finals look like we
had no chances he looked like we were
gonna lose he looked really bad
look those two attended that bye
thinking for 80 seconds
pretty much back to a 50 50.
psg lgd's one game needed to secure the
championship title they are ahead here
in game four the half hour that ensued
was tense and unpredictable
non-stop buybacks barracks trades and
harrowing high-stakes outplays
he's been ruptured he needs help but he
needs it now jared and with the tip of
the hand of god give me that double heal
the relocation as well jax gets him out
i'm trying to get these somebody else to
death based on you want to reload to the
base
[Music]
because obviously everything around you
is telling you it's over
that that's twice in the series the x
nova just comes out
crow is cheering against you
he keeps getting harder you know you
lost one fight two fights still anna
holding on you feel like [ __ ] you feel
like it's impossible they really want to
force this pl to come back here despite
securing mega creeps og were low on
buybacks down two racks themselves and
one team wipe away from watching their
cinderella story fall just inches short
of its magical conclusion
so at 60 minutes when anna got jumped in
the mid lane it looked over at this
stage of the game a single team fight
could decide everything and
unfortunately for og
this team fight started out really badly
for them very very soon to be spawning
roshan and psg lgd are well aware
roshan's up it looks like only og knows
okay
battle
indeed but losing losing action i'm just
gonna get caught up by the tornado
though
they've opened up onto him army trying
to get on top of anna the bkb popped by
chalice he'll get the alt out no tail
getting going out straight away by f5
with a surfboard no tail step for a
hundred with thompson farming jungle
camps and seb split pushing bottom og
weren't whole at the moment the fight
broke loose this meant that no tail had
already been blown up by the time seb
tp'd forcing him jerax and thompson to
scramble as anna staved off a 1v5 and
this is where things got really bad for
og in an effort to isolate seb from his
teammates chalice's brulings and
ex-nova's enchantress start diverting
all their energy towards shutting him
down as soon as somnis's bloodseeker
casts bloodrite an aoe silence that
prevents anyone caught in it from using
their spells seb had to move to get out
of range except crucially he ran left
instead of right cutting him off from
his allies leaving him to watch as they
got torn to shreds by lgd's onslaught
look at the cool controller
has he got it i'm getting stunned by the
call strap but he's able to wait for him
after i've got thompson blinks in he
gets the hex up for that fight with a
snowball save seb tried to re-engage
with shadowblade an item that renders
him invisible to enemy units but
unfortunately x nova had a gem of true
sight to counter that play and was able
to shoo him off while the rest of lgd
took both jerax and thompson out of the
fight leaving only on a standing look at
the bad shots will be able to find the
iron but they're fully low ogd that song
is never two minutes they get thompson
thompson never do it
now at this exact moment
everything all of og's hopes and dreams
were on on a shoulders it looked bad but
anna had a chance his buyback was up his
allies were going to be as well in just
a few seconds and lgd only had one
buyback available which was not enough
to stop og if anna could somehow swing
this fight right here right now og could
bring this game back from the brink the
issue is that it wouldn't be easy see
phantom lancer is a pretty sturdy hero
thanks to his passive illusion
generation but he wins fights by hitting
you over and over and he doesn't have
his own crowd control to enable that
that meant anna had no way to lock down
lgd in order to actually kill them
what's more the second topson went down
lgd saw red all of their attention
shifted onto focusing anna down which
meant that for one split second they
forgot about seb for one moment lgd
weren't tracking his position but that
was all the time he needed they get
thompson thompson
can you do it here he's at our bell
he gets the goal
of his lifetime it's a play so perfect
so incredibly clutch people have knitted
scarves in its honor
seb used his blink dagger to execute a
pixel-perfect berserker's call onto
three of lgd's remaining heroes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now for those who don't know berserker's
call is a taunt that forces anyone
within its area of effect to attack axe
seb also took a talent at level 25 that
increased its range which gave anna the
opening he needed to rip lgd to shreds
sebastian said in the game was like
don't worry guys i'm gonna carry this
game i just need some time this is my
game boys
then you got only pixel commentating the
match when you hear a guy that normally
talks
super fast
just
stop and shout
one word
as he said making a play i think about
this beautiful french man and all i want
to do is shout his name of all the
outplays that made og's run possible to
begin with the crazy upper bracket hole
on his cheeky buyback cell the yule's
dodge
none embody og's untiltable spirit more
than seb's era defining axe call
ti 8 was it was weird when ti-8 was like
i don't know how to describe it it's
like it felt like we couldn't lose for
some reason it felt like it was
impossible to lose it's like some games
like i don't know we were like two sides
behind like 20 i don't even know like
how bad it look
nothing was going for us yet it felt
like this game was fine like it was it
was
sometimes even felt like the game was
easy we were so peaceful in certain
games like maybe we're just lunatics i
don't know it felt like we were not
gonna lose and we didn't but it wasn't
only dota it felt like there was much
more to it not only did og go on to win
that game the following game and the
whole tournament they won the next ti as
well they're just giving look at this
they're diving and ti finals they want
karaoke in the boundary as well they're
gonna get it they're chasing miracles as
well oh my god i can't believe this
i can't believe what we're seeing in
this game for
oh gee
[Applause]
but all of that might never have
happened if it weren't for seb's
incredible call the dynasty began in
that moment with a fateful
earth-shattering reminder that every
second counts there's always a way
there's always a way always and that's
why we like dota as the reason why we've
been playing dolores so much it's the
reason why we think does the best game
is because there's always a way to break
things like no matter how broken it
looks don't like it no matter how
powerful it looks no matter how what the
winner is no matter how strong the teams
are with it
there's always a way
[Music]
on the next episode of every second
counts presented by cisco we're going to
break down the two minutes that made
edward gaming world champions the viper
is still alive though flashes in show
maker down to 200 he's a sitting duck
and it's a double kill for scout now
he's flashing forward picking up all of
the summoner spells and it is good night
for ghost and an ace for edg it's
damwan's unprecedented baron sneak and
edg's incredible team fight from worlds
2021. check it out on january 12th
[Music]
you